what's going on guys today we're doing a
breakdown for the official release
of my hero academia chapter 287 as
you're about to see this is genuinely
one of the most important chapters ever
as we get a solid understanding about
why the vestiges exist
and also whether one fraud can be stolen
as well as an insight into darby's plan
which
i i've kind of like pieced it together
based on information from chapter 271
and also something he mentioned over 200
chapters ago now
so yeah that's gonna be at the end of
the video so be sure to stick around for
that
before we begin uh yesterday i did
stream on twitch for about an hour
but we were talking about this chapter
just literally page by page
so link in the description if that's
more of your type of thing but for this
video we're just talking about the
important details in easter eggs that i
thought were quite interesting
to start things off all 41 gives us a
massive info dump towards the start of
this chapter
that finally clarifies the origin of the
vestiges
he begins by explaining that over the
years whenever he's stolen a quirk from
someone
the original user would sometimes appear
to him in dreams
and basically terrorize him and throw
abuse at him like like an angry ghost or
something
however once he would get rid of the
quirk in question
the former owner would stop haunting him
which led to a realization
every quirk factor that exists contains
a copy of the user's consciousness
this is a terrifying thing to think
about because it means that all the
quirks the doctor had stored in his lab
over the years
contained vestiges that were trapped
alone inside this prison
i knew he was a bad guy but come on man
come on
anyway because of this revelation quirks
like one for all and all for one
are perfect for storing these
consciousnesses which is why all for one
was so
certain that his little brother was
inside one for all
for the longest time we never knew why
the vestiges were a thing especially in
the case of all might for example
because you know all might is very much
still alive and yet he still had a
vestige inside one for all
and now we have confirmation that you
don't have to be dead to have a vestige
because every single quirk contains
these consciousnesses
before we move on to the next thing
there's just two things we should
clarify
number one is that based on everything i
just said for all for one that we see
right here
he is also by definition a vestige
shigaraki was given the original all for
one quirk
which we now know contains a copy of
afo's consciousness
and that is what we're seeing here we're
seeing a copy so
the real awful one is still in tartarus
in both body
and mind and yeah like i said this is
just a copy
of his consciousness following on from
that point number two is that we now
know beyond
a shadow of a doubt that the vestiges
are always watching
and are more powerful than we thought
during the sports festival they watched
deku as he walked out the ring
and consciously intervened to help him
free himself
and likewise afo's vestige was watching
shigeraki fight the heroes
and intervene to save him from endeavour
there are other examples of this
including you know just before shigaraki
destroyed jakku hospital
the first user of one for all appeared
to deku but the point is that they're
constantly
aware of what's going on and if they
want to they can take control and
intervene if
they choose to do so luckily for deku
though his vestiges are a lot nicer than
shiguraki's one
so yeah i doubt the 1 4 users will be
taking over but
it seems you know that they could do
that if necessary
imagine the final fight of this series
was just all might versus all for one
but they were using the bodies of their
successors to fight instead that would
just be
that'd be terrible but it'd be kind of
funny okay so moving on now
can one floor be stolen we all remember
all might saying that it couldn't be
transferred unless the user wants it to
happen
but in this chapter afo straight up
confirms on three separate occasions
that with enough power enough rage afo
can steal one for all i will say that
all might wasn't
lying at the time because the rule that
it can't be taken
does technically still exist it's just
that with enough power you can override
it
luckily during this chapter it was not
taken due to the fact that the all for
one quirk hadn't yet fully absorbed into
shigaraki
because shigaraki has the search quirk
it's just not safe for anyone involved
to uh to have midoriya go back to ua
it'd just be way too easy for the
villains to find him when they want to
and also ua might not even be a thing
depending on what derby's planning to do
back in chapter 82 a clone of dabby
revealed how
in his opinion the two most trusted
foundations of hero society
were ua and the symbol of peace which
was all mine
furthermore during the war arc when
dabby saw tokyomi on the battlefield
he remarked how tacky it was that ue had
students on the front line
also another thing to consider just
before i tell you what i think his plan
is
is that out of all the heroes since all
my retirement
best genius is the one with the highest
popularity rating
so most people in the public prefer best
genius as their favorite hero
with that said this is what i think
darby is planning
we see in this chapter that skeptic
tells dabi that uh shiguraki is fighting
endeavor
and you can see that davey's a bit
shocked he's like surprised to hear this
and he immediately tells skeptic to
start doing prep
when asked what they need to prep for
dabi simply replies by saying
the tearing down of hero society which
is again a call back to what he said
all those chapters ago dabi can
accomplish his mission of destroying the
public's trust in ua by revealing that
during this war
ua put actual students on the
battlefield against these villains
and yeah they may have provisional hero
licenses but come on this environment
that they're in is ridiculously
dangerous way more so
than anything they would have
experienced in their training however it
won't stop there
because if you remember he's been
keeping one big secret about a former ua
student
for a long time and that is of course
best genius
genus was declared missing a long time
ago but as manga readers will know
genus his death was orchestrated by
darby himself
when he basically manipulated hawks into
killing the most popular hero around
let's think about this for a second the
symbol of peace has retired
and the person who has replaced him as
the most popular hero is best genius
that person is then killed by another
pro hero
on live tv i think it's darby's plan to
confirm beyond a reasonable doubt
that hawks killed best genus thereby
just putting the nail in the coffin for
hero society
i imagine skeptic's quirk can come in
useful at this moment
as he could create like a copy of
geniuses corpse for debbie to show to
the world
unless debbie was just carrying it
around with him in one of mr compresses
marbles that you know that's a
possibility too
um but either way we will finally get
the confirmation that genus is dead
honestly it's just gonna be a massive uh
uproar it's gonna be massive controversy
and then when you add on top of that
that endeavor is the
father of derby you know when he reveals
that on tv i mean
i really appreciate darby's patience
because we see he's been playing the
long game you know all the way back
200 chapters ago he revealed what he was
trying to do
and he's just been playing a really long
game manipulating hawks
holding on to his information about
endeavor and now it's all
culminating in this moment where he's
going to reveal everything
anyway there were a few small details
and callbacks during this chapter
so i'm going to list a few of the ones
that i could find and you guys let me
know if there's anything that you
thought
that i missed out that might be
interesting to start with
we get this moment in the vestige world
where deku moves without thinking and
tries to save shigaraki from being
absorbed
in the back you'll notice that there are
six stars that appear out of nowhere
and each one represents the users of one
for all who are not currently there
obviously nana shimura and all for one's
brother were already next to deku
so it's interesting that the other users
would appear in the form of stars
at the exact moment that midoriya gains
the power to move
in this world i didn't notice these
stars when i was doing the live reading
but
afterwards when i checked it again i did
see it so i thought it was worth
mentioning
next up we get this subtle confirmation
from off one
that it was it was him who killed his
own brother we never really knew how the
first user died
but afo straight up says in this moment
that both nana shimura and his brother
fell to him and you know we all know how
it turned out for nana shimura
so the implication is clear this wording
of falling to all for one
um not only does it imply death but also
when we think about who all for one's
brother is
he's not a person who's ever submitted
to all for one you know
even when he was forced to take the
stockpiling quirk which eventually
became one for all
he still managed to turn that into
something against his brother
by passing it to the second user who
passes the third user and eventually
it led to all might who then defeat it
all for one so
even in death orthorn's brother never
submitted to his to his older brother
um so i think the only way this can be
interpreted is that yeah
all for one just killed his brother
additionally
we get this moment with toga and mr
compress
in which he catches her looking for
ochako and deku
among all the destruction essentially
what toga wants to know
is where heroes draw the line when it
comes to who they should save and who
they can kill
back in the provisional license exam
deku saved toga during the exercise
and at the time she was pretending to be
ochako now this was interesting because
deku knew full well that it wasn't
really ochako but he still helped her
anyway
which is something that really intrigued
her as you can see in this panel right
here
she repeats this same line again in the
present day talking about where do they
draw the line because
back in the back in the exam she was
asking him do you just save
anyone or is there a line that you draw
and now she's asking you know she wants
to work out
whether they'd be willing to kill her in
the same way that hawks killed twice
but with that said that's everything i
had for this video
like i said link is in the description
if you want my live reaction
to uh to all of the uh pages from this
chapter i'll be doing another live
reaction this friday on twitch
for chapter 288 so until then peace out